this now the moment when the personal
proved politically fateful for matt
hancock
the health secretary resigning over
pictures of him
breaking his own social distancing
guidance and possibly the law
but his relationship with old friend and
political aid gina colla d'angelo
raising far more than personal scandal
criticism too over his decision to put
her
on the public payroll miss color
d'angelo tonight left her post on the
board at the department of health
as mr hancock realized too he had to go
those of us who make these rules have
got to
stick by them and that's why i've got to
resign
i want to thank people for their
incredible
sacrifices and what they've done
everybody working in the nhs
across social care everyone involved in
the
in the vaccine program and frankly
everybody in this country
who has risen to the challenges that
we've seen
over this past 18 months i'm very proud
of what we've done
to protect the nhs at the peak to
deliver that vaccine rollout for one of
the fastest in the world
and i look forward to supporting
the government and the prime minister
from the back benches
to make sure that we can get out of this
pandemic
we're so close to the end are you
hopeless mr hancock i don't think so
is it your chance to give the version of
events today mr hancock mr hancock had
become used to defending himself in
recent weeks
embarrassingly text messages from the pm
described him as hopeless
former aide dominic cummins told mps mr
hancock was incompetent
a liar unfit for high office and tonight
little option but to hand in his
resignation letter to the pm
who in turn said he was sorry to receive
it
but many colleagues thought mr hancock
had no option
it's okay having the support
and the confidence of the prime minister
but in a pandemic you've also got to
have the support and the confidence of
the public
and although i think they had some
sympathy with him over the affair
it wasn't that it was the perceived
hypocrisy
of telling people to do one thing and
doing another yourself
the labour leader also glad he's gone
but thinks the pm should have pushed him
i think this reveals the weakness lack
of judgment
lack of leadership from boris johnson
that he didn't sack him
and if number 10 are briefing tonight
that this was matt hancock's decision
not boris johnson
i think that tells you even more so that
boris johnson
isn't cut out for the demands of
leadership but with the vaccine rollout
still underway he
does need an experienced leader in such
a demanding department
tonight appointing former chancellor and
home secretary
sajid javid as the new health secretary
the pair last worked together before the
pandemic hit
mr javid returned into the cabinet in
very different circumstances
one old friend and political ally
confident
he said he just taken the appointment
from the prime minister but he knows how
to run
organizations he's run businesses he's
been secretary of state in a number of
departments as well as being the former
chancellor i think that uh he'll give
the nhs an important focus it's a huge
organization a huge
employer he has compassion he believes
in public
service he believes in the public sector
i i think this is a very good
and inspired appointment from the prime
minister
ever since the photos of that embrace
were published and questions around rule
breaking and use of taxpayer money
began building mps aids ministers have
been quietly whispering
that they couldn't see how mr hancock
could cling on indeed one cabinet
minister said to me tonight his
credibility
was completely destroyed and it was the
right thing to do to stand down
and while the prime minister says he's
sorry to see him go
on the upside it means boris johnson
doesn't have to burn through
any of his own political capital
defending his now
former health secretary but on the
downside he's just lost his scapegoat
for when that public inquiry begins
this government and its former health
secretary will have many questions to
answer when that inquiry begins
but for tonight the man who has led on
public health for 15 months
brought down not by his political record
but his personal life
beth rigby sky news westminster